what I want to do in this video is prove
that the opposite angles of a
parallelogram are congruent so for
example we want to prove that C a b c a
b is congruent to b DC so that that
angle is equal to that angle and that a
BD which is this angle is congruent to
DC a which is this angle over here and
to do that we just have to realize that
we've have-we have some parallel lines
and we have some transversals and the
parallel lines and the transversals
actually switch roles so let's just
continue these so it looks a little bit
more like transversals intersecting
intersecting parallel lines and really
you could just pause it for yourself and
try to prove it because it really just
comes out of alternate interior angles
and corresponding angles of transversals
intersecting parallel lines so let's say
that this angle right over here let's
make this let me do it in a new color
since I've already used that yellow so
let's say let's start right here with
angle b d c-- well angle b DC and I'm
just going to I'm just going to mark
this up here angle B DC right over here
it is an alternate interior angle with
this angle right over here with that
angle right over there and actually we
could extend this point over here I
could call this point I could call that
point E if I want so I could say angle
angle C D B is congruent to angle eb d
angle e be d by alternate alternate
interior angles this is a transversal
these two lines are parallel a B or a E
is parallel to CD fair enough now if we
kind of change our thinking a little bit
and instead we now view BD and AC as the
parallel lines and now view a B as the
transversal then we see that angle EB D
is going to be congruent to angle BAC
because they are corresponding angles
they are corresponding angles so angle E
BD
e is going to be congruent to angle to
angle BAC to angle BAC or I could say CA
be angle c a.b they are corresponding
corresponding angles and so if this
angles convert to that angle of that
angle is congruent to that angle then
they are congruent to each other so
angle C let me make sure I get this
right c DB c DB or we could say BD c is
congruent to angle C a B to C a B so
we've proven this first part right over
here and then to prove that these two
are convert we use the exact same logic
so first of all we view we view this as
a transversal we view AC is a
transversal of a B and C D and let me go
here and let me create a let me create
another point here let me call this
point F right over here so we know that
angle ACD angle ACD angle ACD is going
to be congruent to angle FAC to FAC
angle F AC because they are alternate
interior alternate interior angles and
then we change our thinking a little bit
and we view AC and BD is the parallel
lines and a B is a transversal and then
angle FAC angle F AC is going to be
congruent to angle abd because they're
corresponding angles angle F to angle a
BD and they are corresponding angles so
the first time we view this is the
transversal AC is a transversal of a B
and C D which are parallel lines now a B
is a transversal and BD and AC are the
parallel lines and obviously if this is
congruent to that and that is congruent
to that then these two have to be
congruent to each other so we see that
if we have opposite angles are congruent
then or if we have a parallelogram then
the opposite angles are going to be
congruent